as the energy crisis escalates and
winter approaches experts are trying to
model what will happen to supply and
demand in the UK the one question on
everyone's mind can we keep the lights
on
now the National Grid has warned that in
a worst case scenario that might be
difficult its winter Outlook report
outlines a situation where cold still
weather might push demand up at the same
time as wind power generation declines
and if electricity imports from
Neighbors in Europe were to reduce or
stop and the same happened with gas
Imports via interconnectors or liquid
natural gas shipments that could result
in a series of planned three-hour
blackouts for UK households and
businesses however unlikely this is
it conjures images of the 1970s when
power was restricted and Britain was
plunged Into Darkness and a three-day
working week it's one of the reasons Liz
Tross who has previously promised that
energy will not be rationed has been
talking to European counterparts in
Prague trying to make sure they will
send the UK energy if needed well what
we're clear about is that we do have a
good Supply of energy in the UK we're in
a much better position than many other
countries but of course there's always
more we can do and that's why I'm here
working with our partners making sure we
do have a secure energy Supply into the
future the National Grid is now focused
on preventing us ever having an
emergency shortage in the first place
firing up coal power plants could be one
contingency measure and there are new
plans for consumers too people and
businesses are going to be asked to sign
up to a voluntary scheme under which
they'd be paid to avoid using
electricity at times of peak demand that
might mean for example charging an
electric vehicle or using a washing
machine overnight and it's hoped that
that might deliver enough power savings
this winter to help balance supply and
demand
at flow coffee in London Bridge it's
something they're willing to try
anything to avoid blackouts if we go on
blackout in my effort all my fridges it
may affect my machine that's gonna
create me an additional
ways an additional money that I have to
pay to fix them so it's gonna affect the
business and it's gonna affect a lot of
people so yes I'm very scared about that
some say the government should have
started this conversation much sooner
lots of energy experts are really
uncertain about why Liz trust in the
administration are going down this road
you know much of Europe is taking part
in energy demand strategies reducing
their demand Germany Spain in particular
have got lots of very common sense
measures in place you know turn off the
lights when you leave the room don't
have lights on in businesses overnight
these things make sense not only to the
public but also now for our energy
Securities a missed opportunity maybe
but the trust Administration is fearful
of anything that might impact growth
although if the National Grid's worst
case scenario comes to pass this winter
the country will have other things to
worry about
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News